This is an observatory that’s trying to
measure gravitational waves that are distortions
in space-time produced by black holes out
there in the universe.
We measure these distortions with lasers going
back and forth between mirrors, measuring
distances that will change very, very slightly
due to these black holes sending us messages
from millions of years away.
When the theory of relativity was created,
it said that masses in general — and black
holes because they’re very compact — distort
space-time and produce these waves that travel
away at the speed of light.
We want to measure here on Earth what happens
when those black holes were born — when
supernovas exploded, when neutron stars collided
to form a black hole.
And we want to detect the effect of those
astronomical events here on Earth.
It’s something that has never been done
before.
We know gravitational waves exist.
They are predicted by the theory of relativity,
but we have also seen the effects of gravitational
waves from systems that loose energy.
But we have never measured them directly here
on Earth.
That’s the new window to the universe we
want to open.